hey everyone welcome to follow the joopa
notebook that be going through today you
can either go to this bit link right
here to access the github version of
that your own notebook I'll be going
through today or you can go to won't
want to go to that github link you can
quickly similarly go to the Google
collab version of it as well and then
I'll give you a moment to try to read
the bit link and then access it awesome
and then I'll show it later on if you
didn't have time to catch it hey and
then for this Jupiter notebook or you'll
be you'll be going through and having
some installations so just some little
installations that you'd be required to
install if you don't have anything
related to this in your environment you
just do Pippen Conda installs or PIP
installs within your Trouper notebook or
the end of cotton pump you'll be working
with and about me I'm a data analyst at
Autodesk I enjoy coffee running and
working on side projects whenever I can
you can follow me on any of these
platforms Twitter github website and
yeah this is a be testing in Python and
my name is Raul Maldonado and we'll be
going through and the raw formalization
of EB testing or online experimentation
in Python and how a minimal level of how
that implementation look like in
production or C you are working on that
your job now and for this presentation
the information data presented today is
no affiliation with Autodesk or my day
to day my day to day work it only just
pertains to the examples and discussions
that we'll be having and the agenda will
be a brief overview of intro to
statistics relevant statistics that
we'll be utilizing in our discussion an
overview of a B testing
implementation results ending remarks
and hopefully some questions if we have
enough time and yeah enjoy so imagine a
scenario where you as a user are
searching for say a truck on Google
search you enter in something a trail
relevant keywords to search in the
results pop up from that I mean
hopefully an entertaining to that
there'll be some relevancy to that and
within those search results ads can
appear as well at the top of those
search results and they'd they would be
at the top and here for example I just
look for like trucks for sale and some
ads would pop up and imagine we have a
campaign called a that is relevant to
vending search results and we want the
user as a business we want the user to
enter in our website and what that would
look like from our end or a platform
that's supporting tracking that
information this data which show like
either username email or an ID or a
universal ID quote you you ID in a
related action to that may be a campaign
associated to that potential click or no
click or what's called an impression and
then a timestamp or date relevant to
that and then similarly for that ad
campaign safe we had if you notice
another campaign called be you and
pertaining to campaign be we'll talk
about that a little bit more in just a
brief moment but that's the existing I'm
so not a scenario from user perspective
and then for us as a business our
experiment goals is for at the core of
what our objective is we just want the
user to just enter in our website in
aspirations to hopefully have them
become a converted customer for whatever
product or service are offering that we
have had from that ad and so at the core
of this objective we just
want the user to click a button and go
into our website and then before going
into the introduction of a/b testing and
then continue further from that scenario
let's just create some fake data and
then just talk about some of the
statistical introductory concepts that
we're gonna work on utilize in our a/b
testing so here I provided an ad hoc
function just to generate some data just
run that through if you're operating on
that report notebook right now and the
end results you should get something
similar to this as a data frame you'll
have two different frames data frame
called campaign 1 or campaign a and then
campaign to you respectively campaign B
which I previously mentioned and results
may vary so if you run this function
over and over again you'll get a
randomized set of output for your
resulting data to work on within your as
you're working on alongside this with me
okay quick stats overview that I
previously mentioned we're gonna quickly
talk about the concepts of or
definitions of mean variance and
standard deviation to your lies within
our you be testing process so the mean
is the calculate old sum of values
divided by the total count of these
values being all summed up or in this
formula here formula right here this
mean would equal this this definition
and going down into an implementation of
what they mean would be how it that
would be calculated say we have the
first divide five values of campaign a
which are here nine fifteen thirteen six
and thirteen it take the total sum of
that we'd get a total of 56 and then
dividing the count of those values we
get an end result of 56 divided by five
which is eleven point two so that's what
the
this definition would look like in
implementation there and then now for
the variance variance is the measure of
spread of a given set of values for for
your given array and it's defined as
this formula right here here so it's the
sum squared differences you know the
difference of the the difference from
the mean for each value squared and
until some of them divided by the total
number of values and here's the
calculation of that variance right here
so we first take the differences of
those original five set of values
subtracted by the mean that was
previously calculated take the square
root of the square root the power to two
of the of those values take the total
sum then divided it by n to get the
resulting variance value and then the
standard deviation is similar to the
variance is just the square root of the
variance seen and defined as this
formula right here so taking the square
root of that previously mentioned value
it's kind of got off but we're taking
the square root of that would be some
around like 2.5 I think yeah it's kind
of cut off okay and then now for that
from that quick overview of in terms of
statistics and that we'll be doing in
the concepts that we would be utilized
in a/b testing let's actually go through
the overview of a/b testing now so
recall there's two ad campaigns a and B
a was the original one from our original
search for a truck so but then we also
had a campaign B that was established
that we'd also want to implement and
show an exposed to a different distinct
set of users as well to compare and we
want to compare these the performances
between these two
campaigns though they would be very
similar with differences of say their
call to action for example a campaign a
it could be something like can I have
the text click here please and then ad
campaign B would have something very
similar to that but with the call to
action it would say learn more here in a
quick example that is say this is
campaign a and that truck cell that
you're potentially looking for this an
ad came up for that needs a decided to
click that and then the call to action
here would be click here please and then
for campaign B say if you had that out
there you would have a a similar style
of that ad campaign but in the in the
text or call to action it would say
learn more here and now we want to
understand the performance between each
ad campaign so should we just by
observation once seeing the performance
of these two for a given set of time and
a given set a number of users who were
just either performance and just kind of
guesstimate like which one is better or
is there a better method to compare
these two ads so statistically one
method we can turn to is for a be
testing for determining this online
experimentation but what is a be testing
a be testing is a randomized online
experiment between two variants a and B
it could also be between different
variants though there are different
assumptions calculations associated with
that associated with that and today
we'll be going through just the
comparison of one group and comparing
that between that and another group and
this is this comparison is done through
one comparison of a single metric of
choice with assumptions as well and
essentially there are adaptations of
hypothesis tests but just referring in a
different manner for for maybe Marquis
purposes or something to pitch to
business leaders say like hey we can do
an AP test and they kinda have the
context so and also the potential
benefits in the business context to to
implement and just in the summary AV
tasks or like just like hapa 'this is
TAS but just we're framed in a different
way a different cool way yeah and then
no review a be testing just an in an
abstract and I found this visualization
very appealing by Allen Downey on an
article published in the 2000s called
probably overthinking it but we have a
initial null hypothesis or assumption of
indifference we have a data from that
and then with the comparison piece two
days we do a calculation through a test
statistic and then through some
threshold or be observed affect this
Delta star value we determine and
compare for the this test statistic
calculation and that threshold in
determining if the the comparison
between these group two groups is
statistically significant or not but
that would be under the assumption of we
would go in through the implementation
of of ensuring that there is no
difference between the two groups and
don't talk about that more in depth but
this is just like high level abstraction
of what the a/b test implementation
would look like okay and then within
that test statistic statistic portion
there are also a lot of assumptions
needed and also how you curate and
determine the types of questions in for
might to determine the right test
statistic to calculate because in fact
there are
[Music]
a variety of options and for your
calculating your test statistic
depending on the objective that you're
trying to reach the questions your
you're asking but also the type of data
that you have in like what amounts of
data you have as well so the sources
just grabbed from an online PDF file
from an academic website the source is
kind of hidden if you in Japan OPIC
you'll see a hyperlink to that but for
in in those statistics courses what they
help introductory statistics courses
help you out and determining is like
okay what's going to like one side of
the spectrum and see for some type of
data and size of data what calculation
or what decisions you would need to go
through to make your calculations and
then also as a next level T that is okay
what about the other side of the
spectrum of like different types of data
that you'd look like look at like
proportions and how would you determine
a test to stick a test statistic
calculation based off a branch of
dependency is on what you need to make
for the decision every test statistic
and then commentary to that is there can
be some comparisons between to two tests
like the t-test and chi-square test the
implementation will be going through for
this discussion will be going through
proportions eat t-test and Zito's and
using the functionality of that but
equivalently what we're going to go
through can be done through chi-squared
tests as well and then chi-squared
implementation would be in the
additional information section of that
Juber notebook and there's just a lot of
spiel right now going on about like warm
perk in preparation for the actual a be
test so thank you for bearing with me
it's a lot to wrap around and also
compact into the initial portion of the
presentation but let's go ahead and get
started with
going through and running a a B test
implementation and keep in mind a
following procedure we're gonna state
our hypothesis have a lot of assumptions
and a lot of preparatory setup or
mentions of that preparatory setup do
the analysis or lateral calculation of
that test statistic in that overview
abstraction I've talked about from Allen
Downey and then make our make a
conclusion as well and have some like
ending remarks from that that test and
then keep in mind to be careful in the
construction of the a be testing as well
in the commentary and a little bit more
discussion that about that would be
mentioned in conclusion and ending
remarks all right so let's go through
testing so initially I mentioned again
that we want to have a metric of choice
to utilize in or Rab Testament ation
implementation and we wanted users to at
least click click our call to action to
enter in to our website whatever that
may be literally whatever that may be
and within that we would want to have
the not the success to what that event
was and there's a particular metric of
choice of that and at core is um became
[Music]
as like a core like foundational metric
for like the emergence of online a be
testing which was clicked the rates now
there are other metrics of choice to you
utilize outside outside the
click-through rate but that would depend
again on what your business objectives
are or what your objectives are for your
experimentation or what you're trying to
value and the click-through rate is just
to find out the total number of
successes or clicks divided by the total
number of events and the total number of
events is the summation of the successes
plus those not so much successes or
what's called impressions before your
own online experimentation
and so now we want to state our
hypothesis we come out the initial
assumption for our click-through rate
for both respective campaigns a a and B
let's define them as P or the
click-through rate P's hat subscript 1
and respectively P hat subscript 2 for
campaign a and B respectively and state
the initial null hypothesis that hey
they click the rate for a campaign a
that's there is no difference between
that and the click-through rate for
campaign B or D equals 0 the difference
between these two is insignificant or is
equal to 0 where D is equal is d is
defined as the difference between those
two click-through rates an alternative
hypothesis is d does not equal 0 which
is the difference between these two is
substantially not they actually are not
like indifferent they do have some
statistical difference to them and
respectably also within our statement of
hypothesis we establish a level
significance alpha and set that to equal
0.05 and this was just one permutation
of staying your no extend your
hypothesis particularly with the
alternative hypothesis there are three
different ways you can state that the
alternative hypothesis you can have a
difference on both sides one side or
another side very vague I know I have a
visualization right here to help that
and explain that out so here we have our
distribution of from our data and we are
right here at this point where a value D
this is just about source does not equal
to some value which would be 0 and so we
would want to see for alternative
hypothesis is there a difference in
either direction
and if there is there's that calculated
test statistic value you fall within the
range pumped in this probability range
which in this case right here would be
alpha divided by 2 and alpha divided by
2 you but in one test one tailed test
for a B tests we can have this set to
equal to half point alpha and there's
another visualization that will depict
that as well with the alpha value would
look like but these are the three
different choices for your alternative
hypothesis within your statement of your
hypothesis and again this just depends
on the question that you would want we'd
want to ask and then here again we want
to emphasize that we are under the
assumption that there is no differences
between the two ads and we're trying to
determine if there is a significant
difference between the two ads or what
are more abstractly what are between the
opportunities are we trying to identify
if there is a statistical significant
difference between these two groups and
the reason why I emphasize this is
because you wouldn't
it's very cautious and risky to come in
front facing in the determined trying
determining and try to show with
conviction that there is a difference
because that and in similar analogy you
wouldn't want to be going into an
evaluation of something nari be
justified as being guilty of some action
that you've been accused of which in
fact you may you may not be guilty of
something so it's the analogy I have
there for why we should focus on coming
into the a/b test implementation and
coming out a standpoint of there is no
significant difference between these
these two groups and then I mentioned
and a level significance value alpha
what is that I'm quite explain that in
the previous slide but that is
our level significance and the
probability of a study or an online
experiment rejected being rejecting the
null hypothesis H naught given that the
null hypothesis were true and then
similarly we would have a confidence
level one minus alpha so one minus 0.05
which is equals a point 95 that is the
probability of failing to reject the
null hypothesis given that is true and
that be considered like a true positive
seeing a visual coming up but then also
there's other two considerations you
should have between determine between
your decision and then what is the
reality of in your comparison beta is
the probability of failing to reject the
null hypothesis H naught when H naught
is false that is the probability of
sticking to our ways given that there is
statistical if evidence that the
alternative scenario h h a or the
alternative hypothesis does exist and
lastly the probability you mention is 1
minus beta which is considered power as
the probability of rejecting the null
hypothesis H naught when each naught or
the new hypothesis is false and then a
quick commentary that the alpha value
and power levels are traditionally just
set to 0.8 E and point 0 5 and I could
in academia examples and then a lot of
online tutorials but depending on your
implementation or the background you're
in or what you're trying to study for
this alpha and beta value or your level
of significance and power could be
different depending again on that
scenario for example in quantum physics
the the south of value would be
substantially like smaller than what is
traditionally shown especially right
here
I'm documentation and the following was
now as I promised to some visualization
of why I summarized between alpha 1
minus alpha beta and then 1 minus beta
this is borrowed from
from em and all resources on accuracy
precision like the beginning
introductory discussions on on on
regression in ml but what I can bring to
this analogy is that alpha value is a
type 1 error it's a false positive where
you where you reject the this is saying
is like you reject that there that there
is no difference forward like oh yeah
there's really is a difference been fact
there was no difference so that's a type
winner and then a true positive which
would be that one minus alpha or
comments level we would have the true
positive which is our 1 minus beta value
or that power value mentioned in type 2
error would be a beta and another
visualization to show for that is this
say this is our null hypothesis and this
is alternative hypothesis
imagine this area was a little bit more
this area was increased little bit more
in this set alpha but this is another
visual representation of what's going on
this is our got a probability of that
falls positive here is that probability
of of a type 2 error and then here is
our power and then right here would be
our confidence level and then there are
a lot of basic assumptions again that I
mentioned had a pretty ad nauseam but
there's a reason justification for doing
that is yata sh ensured that the
experimentation framework is set up
propria lean because you don't want
false positives to occur depending on
how you calculate your metrics score how
how variant your data your collected
data could be because there could be in
the business other implementations yeah
testing implementations are crying at
the same time that you may not be aware
of that could be production issues where
your data is not appropriately coming in
from one or mean edu sources there is
the how is your sampling distribution
being out for for a user assigned to a
campaign if they're participating in
that experimentation is it is it truly
random or kylie and also is their
assignment random and distinct where
they wouldn't go into the other ad
campaign as well if they refresh their
their Google search and then also the
assumption of central limit theorem as
well as the and then that's just this
discussion on sample size which can be
covered later on if there is enough time
at the ending portion and then I'm gonna
skip this portion but basically a data
transformation of our pre-existing
collected data set and showing the
distribution of what that data would
look like for the click-through rates
and notice for say for example a size of
1,600 utilizing a central limit theorem
this in the distribution of those click
the rates with a sort approach some
normality as the number of the size of
your data would become more big okay and
now for analyzing the results we'll be
utilizing the proportion t-test
calculation there again or other there's
one other type of way to calculate a
proportion value particularly click the
rates which I'll come up to you priests
and or towards the end which is right
here is that our T and T statistic
statistic calculation is equal to that
difference D minus zero or zero where
zero is that initial value there is no
difference between those two groups and
divided by a standard error and the
standard error would look like this
formula right here where it's the it's
right thing and then when comparing
these two groups just not the notation
that the the difference is equal to the
difference
they click the rate proportion about
campaign 1 - ad campaign 2 and let's go
in the head and go through some manual
approach the function I utilize to
create this manual approach was a bit
long and went over the slide so I went
ahead and chunked it out bit by bit so
if you're following on in the trooper
notebook um after cell 37 you'll see
markdown files of what that breakdown of
the function would look like so in the
initial portion we have our parameters
um for group 1 and group 2 a set alpha
value and then what are printed out
alpha information would come out to and
then this is all a customized function
if you dilute utilize it say in a non
data frame object you may get some
errors so but again this functions just
utilized for our discussion here and as
manual cleared
created so right here we have the
calculation for our click-through rate
for ad campaign 1 so we're just going
for that group or D data frame this
total sum of those clicks divided by the
total number of occurrences that have
occurred the whole summation of
occurrences of successes and impressions
or non clicks and then somewhere for ad
campaign - we would get a similar
click-through rate calculation taking
the difference of that we'd store in a
very Baldy on to the next portion of
that same function and going down we
would calculate the standard error since
these values are more under the
assumption of Independence we calculate
ap overall the first standard error
portion term within the standard error I
showed previously utilizing P overall
and then we similar similarly calculate
the standard error term within that
square root value for the overall
standard error
and then going down we have calculate
manually calculate the t-statistic value
that was defined in this function right
here let's go down here so D minus zero
divided by that standard error and then
we have a degrees of freedom being
calculated here so the total number
occurrences for the group or a campaign
a plus campaign be divided
Demond subtracted by just two values to
give degree freedoms degree of freedom
and that's utilized in the calculation
for our our T critical value or that
threshold value we're going to use to
compare to the calculated T statistic
previously-mentioned
now and this is utilize this T critical
value at that thresholds utilize and
making our decision however there are
two other ways to go about and making a
decision though they have their
assumptions advantages and disadvantages
coming up and then this is just a print
out text of our everything in summation
from this function I'm soon to be
outputted this is all text as well and
the return everything was returned in
this portion right here of the function
and will be shown soon but previously I
just mentioned that there there's a
three like three ways to go about and
determining the results information
information there is the comparison for
your T statistic determining if that's
greater than the critical value T
critical in making your decision there
is in I view of it like using utilizing
it what's a confidence interval for your
previous calculations but then most
importantly and as a focus in in briefs
and resources research and like
implementation on my experimentation
something called the p-value and so this
probability p value is the probability
of attaining and in fact that least as
Extreme as the one you observed in the
sample data assuming again that the null
hypothesis is true
and this is again one that's most highly
utilized about the same time a method
for making decisions that can be it be
used as well because within this if in
the business context if you utilize this
and criteria in for your decision-making
to business leaders and that's the only
thing that business leaders understand
in the context of making a decision then
they fail to realize that the the
assumptions they still needed me to make
but there aren't translated to you to to
to those leaders just because they like
that lacking context and considerations
as a statistician or as an experimenter
that the information is lost so on
Twitter there are some statisticians
grad students at hashtag stats Twitter
that you have concerns with the p-value
and also would like and highly like to
mention that outside of just showing a
p-value or a resulting decision from
that p-value that you also need to
communicate the underlying assumptions
as well from your tasks and here's the
output for utilizing that customized
function right here so here we have the
click the rates established right here
for a and B respectively the coffin
symbol calculated if needed
the calculated T statistic the T
critical value of 1.65 and in a p-value
of 0.6 and then within this the criteria
is P less than alpha if if that is true
then we would make a decision to say
that there is a statistical significant
difference between - between between the
two groups here but since it's not in
this case for the this first iteration
or implementation of our a/b test we see
that our we fail to reject that null hoc
fail to reject the null hypothesis and
conclude that there is no difference
between the two groups right now
and here's just some comments someone in
regards to that conclusion but very
quickly there's a non manual approach to
go about calculating your test statistic
which will be will in this case will be
utilizing stat model library and
utilizing the proportion Z test function
and previously - I mentioned there are
proprietary software that enables you to
do online experimentation with the knee
without the need of going through this
little kind of low-level abstract
abstract and then and then similarly
there are open source packages available
like plan out and Mesabi tell p with
your online experimentation as well but
those those those packages and
software's have their advantages - did
its disadvantages when utilizing them
but here we'll be using that proportion
z test in the calculation of the firm RT
data frames gain the total number of
child successes the total number of
occurrences for the clicks and no clicks
the value that we want to compare to in
this case is 0 and then what permutation
that we need to make in our initial
statement of a hypothesis throws to
one-sided statement of hypothesis and
then it was like a two-sided case and
then from that you don't inputting those
information in the parameter of that
function we get the resulting T
statistic and p-value that would is go
equivalent to the manual calculation
from previous and then that's just
pretty much pit for it like calculation
utilizing great two packages methods or
proprietary software I like that and
then similar to that we have that end
result decision and however there can be
if there are multiple iterations of the
same test at some point there could be
false positive or each and they're your
statement conclusion in some cases
though this is we fail to reject the
null hypothesis and still stick with it
there could be cases where we could
reject null hypothesis and in fact that
may not be true and that's where we
reach
that type 1 error or that level
significance and within this always be
testing but in the sense of a caution
because the more Internet we try to go
and be confident getting conclusive and
results or what we hope for then we
forget the knowledge that we have and in
in in court and in considerations we
have of like what like what if this
scenario isn't true or more simply
ignorance more frequently begats
confidence than does knowledge hi
there's so I know this was all focused
on a frequentist approach to a beats
tests do you have any recommendations on
where to find guides for taking a more
Bayesian approach to a/b testing why are
some resources for a/b testing in
Bayesian sense there is online packages
PI MC 3 that is available for you to
review but then there's a little
emergency of online books and
implementation of B's and Bayesian a/b
testing as well I can't name the books
off the top and I had there was one book
that I could name out and survey LeBlanc
Amazon's
be Bayesian fun way the fun way of
learning be Bayesian statistics by will
William Kurt and that's something I
couldn't provide pre soon yeah okay if
there are no other questions and thank
you very much roll for sharing your
information with us thank you
[Applause]